[Musique]
pour le moment les cherry s'est tout de
suite danse avec émis hier
[Applaudissements]
sur la tête de ma mère la régie les
chéris elle est la nature
on dirait que je fais un duplex en
direction mexique les gars un truc de
ouf
non mais ça après nous attentions
première danse sur une salsa kelly et
son partenaire benjamin castaldi annonce
ainsi tomber bon d'accord fin au but
chinois
alors est regardée bon pour moi je alors
c'est moi qui met les notes mais je mets
un pays en crise
un sur dix attention sur une mc amène à
kelly et sa partenaire valérie bella il
bien sûr
attention sur une breakdance areli et
celle ci datant de gavage ans kelly et
son partenaire maxime dillies
[Musique]
avertissements ces bons jeux mais je
mets 4 ans et donald j l'énergie
attention ils peuvent sur des spas sitôt
kelly et son partenaire damien cannibale
ragga radars au-dessus ohlala
à
[Musique]
ces mots stado frage m et jean michel
maire on l'a pas eue jean michel maire
d'un d'espacil taux de réponses alors
elle va jean-michel vert sur des espaces
isolés
donnez moi les professionnels hilali du
car est ce que tu veux tu vas nous bien
ils peuvent refuser ce que tu veux
danser avec rachid arhab et jean luc
lemoine ou non sur n'importe quoi c'est
en train de me dire non est ce que tu as
pris ta décision qui est pour toi qui as
été pourquoi ton meilleur partenaire de
danse relève valérie on enlève valérie
c'est maxime c'est maxime toinon nul
nantua nul maxime et kelly j'ai
l'honneur
vous annoncez que vous partez tous les
deux pour un stage de danse dans le
limousin
payez pas la production a donné aux
parts et une semaine tous les deux dans
suffira pas voilà il y aura dans ce bien
sûr et bien sûr je serai fargniers n'ya
pas star heureux heureux et épanoui et
balaj et lahi mécontente ah oui ça a
l'air en deux versions
[Applaudissements]